[Music]
foreign
everyone busy show lined up for you but
we start with breaking news on the
economy with new figures just out for
inflation in December how's it looking
all important of course for those
workers who are planning to go on strike
Paul Kelso is with us hey Paul good
morning tell us more
uh yeah good morning Kay these are the
latest inflation figures from the office
for National statistics uh for the end
of last month of last year an inflation
ran at 10.5 percent that is in line with
expectations it is a small tick
downwards from the uh above 11 in the
end of the Autumn but it is still while
that has eased the price pressure a
little it's just the rate of increase
that's going down it is still a
staggeringly high figure 10.5 percent
equals yesterday morning we were talking
about the pressures in the labor market
and the jobs market and the fact that
real terms wages were falling uh once
inflation had been taken into account
despite pay rise who's being given out
by both the private and to the lesser
extent the public sector uh money in
your pocket by the time you come to
spend it in the real world was worth
less well that is going to continue with
this High inflation number 10.5 some of
the easing caused by a reduction in fuel
price prices people who have noticed it
is a little cheaper at the pump for
diesel and petrol all those still high
by historic levels high energy costs
exacerbated by the war in Ukraine and
we're very familiar with it but it's
still driving inflation and food
inflation remains High something
everybody notices uh when we are in the
shop so the headline figure this morning
is inflation has eased a little but it
is still very very high 10.5 percent
and what's the prediction for inflation
going forward in 2023
the expectation guys it will fall and
that the uh some of the factors that are
driving inflation will ease although
there are some big big unknowns in there
not least the course of the war in
Ukraine some of it will be technical uh
gravity if you like economic gravity
will bring inflation down because as the
year ticks round uh the number of the
amount that prices have risen will
simply be less because we're used to
inflation at this level so it will fall
the bank again inspects it to perhaps
half by the middle of the year the prime
minister of course has made that one of
his commitments but essentially economic
gravity should bring it down remember
just because inflation falling it
doesn't mean prices are falling prices
are still Rising just a little less
slowly uh fast forgive me absolutely
thanks so much Andy Paul thanks let's
put that to the immigration Minister
Robert January should we good morning
nice to see you thanks for joining us
thoughts on the inflation figures well I
think it's the first positive
alternative signs of improvement but
there's a long way to go here we see
being that there is an improving
situation internationally as Energy
prices begin to fall but I don't want to
overstate how impactful that will be in
the short term and this is something
that the government's clearly going to
work very closely on and do everything
that we can to contribute to the full
inflation that's why the Prime Minister
made this one of the central five
objectives of this government in 2023
um the union leaders obviously will be
looking at very closely indeed as well
they're wanting to link pay Rises to the
inflation figure Steve Barkley the
health secretary writing in the
independent suggesting that strikes
could go on for another three months are
you with the same opinion well I
certainly hope not but that's really in
the hands of the trade unions we want to
be as reasonable as possible Steve
Barkley and other ministers have been
meeting with Union representatives to
talk to them to see if there are ways
forward to discuss next year's pay
settlement and set out our arguments on
affordability there but I think what you
see with inflation today means that if
the international factors are beginning
tentatively to work in the right
direction the worst thing that we could
do domestically would be to
significantly increase public sector pay
and then entrench inflation in the
British economy and get into a kind of
wage spiral that will be very
detrimental to the economy so we have to
approach this with great caution because
inflation is the big evil that's the
thing that's diminishing people's
savings is increasing interest rates and
mortgage rates and making life generally
harder for everyone and so we have to
approach these public sector pay
discussion with that broader mission in
mind which is to bring down inflation by
at least 50 over the course of this year
and to that end you know you can take on
uh the rail unions you can take on uh
the civil servants unions but you know
when it comes to taking on the nurses
you don't have the support of the of the
British people and and I've seen the
banners that say a nurses for life not
just for covert well we have great
respect for nurses of course we do I'll
give them well it's not always as simple
as that in life argument okay because
what we have to judge is not only how
can we motivate and respect nurses and
there is a serious challenge with
retention and recruitment within the NHS
we have to balance that however with
General affordability to the taxpayer
what can the NHS with its record level
of investment right now afford secondly
the point about inflation which is so
critical to everybody in this country
and thirdly how can we manage this in a
sensible and appropriate great Manner
and the way that's done is through
independent pay review bodies and there
was an independent pay review last year
which concluded that nurses should get
the pay rise that they have we accepted
their recommendations this isn't an
independent is it it is independent okay
is it not presided over by the Prime
Minister and lots of government
ministers are involved in deciding how
much that money is well government
ministers play a role in it in that we
submit recommendations and give a
mandate to the independent pay review
body and we're doing that now for next
year the next financial year but then
it's ultimately for that group of
experts to look at the evidence to
listen to the perspective of the
workforce of trade unions
and come to a balanced judgment isn't it
don't ministers tell that pay review
body how much is in the past well we do
say what's affordable as you'd expect
because when any business or
organization considers how much it can
afford to pay its staff it has to work
out what is in the pot if you like like
but they also take into account what's
happening in the economy where inflation
is and is likely to be over the course
of the year and the particular
challenges in that sector to do with
Recruitment and Retention and at the
moment the independent period is gearing
up to work out what it should be a fair
second for the next financial year and
that's really our Focus right now and
they will be taking account of the
inflation on the first of February and
the fact that that's a coordinate
coordinated day of action it is
absolutely and one of my
responsibilities as immigration
ministers to keep our borders secure and
allow passengers to flow through our
airports as efficiently as possible and
so I'm working very hard to see that if
that strike includes border Force
personnel as it did over Christmas and
New Year that we have the right response
and I hope you and your listeners will
agree that the response we put in place
over Christmas and New Year was a good
one we use 600 Armed Forces Personnel 50
percent of border staff came into work
despite the strike action and actually
our borders were as secure as usual and
flowed if anything better than they do
on a normal working day and so that's
the kind of detailed work that I'm
involved in right now so that we can try
to ensure the country works as well as
it can on that day but the key thing is
that the unions don't proceed with those
strikes because all it's going to do
well they're going to well that's a
matter for them it is we can only
prepare but what I my message to them
would be think about the impact it's
going to have on working people across
the country and on the economy we know
that times are difficult right now what
we don't want to see is the economy
harmed by you know an act of self-harm
by further strike action that makes it
harder to get to work to cross the
border and of course to get access to
crucial Public Services okay can we
better not let me talk about her to you
if I may um she has been writing in oh
she's um there's an article let's say in
the telegraph today about uh um
transgender conversation vision therapy
she has said she's not actually written
to MPS as yet I believe Tory MPS but she
wants the ban on trans conversion
therapy not to criminalize parents I'm
not quite sure where she's going with
that do you understand that yes I do
we all support the abolition of
conversion therapies which are you know
malicious attempts to convince people to
live lives outside of their gender and
so Banning people from doing those kind
of courses or interventions is
absolutely the right thing but this is a
much more complex issue than perhaps it
seems at first glance what we don't want
to see happen is parents loved ones
teachers people who want to provide
support and advice to Children put off
or criminalized from doing so if you're
a young person who is trans or is
thinking through the issues related to
trans it is absolutely right that you
should be able to turn to your parents
or trusted adults for support and advice
at that time and as a parent it is
absolutely right that I could provide
that kind of advice and support to my
chart without fear or without fear of
either being criminalized or there being
some other sanction as a result of doing
so so the way in which this new law will
need to be drafted is one which strikes
that balance so that the malicious
activities are criminalized and are
consigned to history but that
well-meaning loved ones and trusted
advisors to children can provide the
support and advice that they need to do
okay and so the way we're going to
handle this as a government is to do
detailed pre-legitive scrutiny which
those colleagues in Parliament who are
rightly concerned about how this will
work in practice can contribute to and
then we will craft careful legislation
in due course we're not going to rush
into this because I think it's a
surprisingly complex issue which we need
to treat appropriately okay we're almost
out of time but I wanted to ask you
about David Carrick that disgusting
disgraceful police officer who managed
to carry out a significant number of
rapes while he worked for the
Metropolitan Police my question is
twofold who is responsible for him being
allowed to stay in his post for 18 years
and should he have his pension removed
from him well on the on the second of
those two points
um the forfeiture of the pension is a
matter for the mayor of London but we
support his efforts to remove that
pension if that is indeed what he
chooses to do you know this is one of
the most egregious cases of police
misconduct in the history of the Met
perhaps in the history of British
policing and this disgusting individual
should not benefit from his years
serving in the metropolitan police there
now needs to be a very detailed
investigation as to exactly what
happened and who might have known about
this during his years of service Sir
Mark Rowley who's leading the
Metropolitan Police is focused on that
the Home Secretary has met with him to
get explicit assurances that he will be
working now intensively to understand
the events how this could possibly have
happened for such a prolonged period of
time and what we can do to make sure it
never happens again and then secondly
we've asked Dame Elish uh Angelini to do
a comprehensive review for us about the
culture in the Police Service about
vetting and recruitment procedures why
these cases of misogyny and Prejudice
seem to happen time and again and what
we can learn from that and we're asking
every police constabulary in the country
to improve their vetting and recruitment
procedures and giving them the funding
to do so there are other important
pieces of work on going like for example
from Dame Louise Casey who I've worked
very closely with in the past have the
utmost respect for and so I hope that
this body of work there was ongoing even
before we learned about this disgusting
case will enable change to happen
finally in the met and other police
force across the country we must leave
it there lots for us to unpick
throughout the course of the program
thank you very much indeed thank you for
the time much appreciated thank you
quick look at what the papers are saying
this morning starting with the guardian
the guardian leading with growing calls
for an investigation into how these
self-confessed rapist David Carrick was
allowed to be a metropolitan police
officer just here and there from the
immigration Minister and the government
feeling that it's up to the mayor of
London whether his pension is rescinded
but certainly the government would
support that if that's what he so
choosed chose even the mail reports that
despite his crimes Carrick may still be
allowed that pension um not if it's
anything to do with the mayor of London
the Metro reports on Industrial action
across multiple sectors on the 1st of
February I'm also talking about that to
the minister as rail staff teachers
University lecturers and civil servants
across a number of government
departments will all stop work
the mirror claims that rather than
paying nurses a fair wage the government
is offering 40 pounds an hour to people
willing to cross their picket lines
and the front of the times carries a
warning from the boss of the food
standards agency about the dangers of
bringing cake into the office it's
apparently just as harmful as passive
smoking
no it's not no it's not still to come on
the program for you as the UK government
blocks Scotland's gender Reform Bill
speaking to the smp's spokesperson for
Scotland Dr Philippa Whitford
flavors Shadow attorney general Emily
Thornbury with us at just after eight
and as further strikes are announced for
train drivers joined by the Secretary
General of aslef Mick Whelan
well as we were discussing there with
the minister thousands of nurses across
England are beginning a two-day strike
today over pay these nurses strikes are
affecting 55 NHS trusts in England
thousands of appointments will be
canceled but chemotherapy intensive care
and neonatal services will all be
protected as it stands nurses will
strike again on the sixth and also the
7th of February but before that a big
day of strikes on the 1st of February
which the trades Union Congress has
earmarked for a coordinated action
involving over a hundred thousand civil
servants 70 000 University staff in the
ucu teachers in England and Wales
joining an ongoing strike in Scotland
over 23 000 schools will be affected on
that day and the rmt rail Union is also
staging a walkout and if that wasn't
enough as left train drivers Union
announcing yesterday that they'll strike
that day as well after rejecting the
latest pay offer
goodness joining us now is shiman she's
at a picket line at University College
Hospital in central London this morning
hi it's good to see you uh tell us
what's going on there this morning
good morning well strike action is due
to start today around 8 A.M but as you
can see behind me the picket line is
starting to form shape now this is going
to be the second wave of strike action
from the Royal College of Nursing it
follows strike action that was taken
last year and it's overpay and working
conditions the Royal College of Nursing
Union that says that nurses pay hasn't
risen in line with inflation and because
of that nurses are struggling and it's
having a huge knock-on effect to patient
safety as well the General Secretary of
the RCN said that this strike action is
taking place with a heavy heart I'm
actually joined now with a nurse that is
going to be on the picket line this
morning Anna Swift you've been a nurse
for over 25 years haven't you why have
you decided to take strike action this
morning I think Pat Cullen says it
really well we take strike action with a
heavy heavy heart but a clear mind about
what we want to achieve we know that
patient safety is at risk every single
day we are sure staffed we have low
morale and it's not just about the pay
it's about the unique contribution that
nursing makes to Patient Care throughout
their Journey whether it's a diagnosis
whether it's at the emergency department
whether it's at the end of their life
nurses are integral to what we do as a
healthcare system and we can't go on
like this it's time to take some action
to say we need better pay we need better
conditions and it is all about our
patient safety at the end of the day and
you've been a nurse for 25 years in that
time watch change what's Driven you to
the picket line this morning I think
it's the pressure I think it's really
fascinating that over covid we worked so
hard so incredibly hard but we all had a
single goal and a single purpose it
feels like that's all gone and it feels
like people are being disingenuous to
our profession and we are so so
important what we do is nobody else does
in the health care service nurses are
integral to What patients achieve and
what we can do perfect thank you very
much for sharing that with Vienna it is
a bitterly cold morning but we are
expecting dozens and dozens of nurses to
turn up today for strike action they say
that the government need to get around
the table to discuss pay negotiations
okay thank you
cutting back on alcohol meeting up with
people and regularly challenging your
brain are among 12 recommendations to
reduce your risk of developing
Alzheimer's a new study by the
Alzheimer's research UK suggests
following what they call a brain
check-in it could cut cases in the UK by
up to 40 percent here's Saba with more
Ian's battle with Alzheimer's lasted
nine years back for pushing you along
Campbell stopper pushing you along at
first the changes were subtle but very
quickly his family noticed things went
from bad to worse
you see the person you knew just
disappearing in front of your eyes and
losing different aspects of their
personality their ability to socialize
eventually in Dad's case his ability to
speak
now two years after Ian's death Stuart
has often wondered whether his fate will
mirror that of his fathers
he got a bit of a fan club coming so
he's taken matters into his own hands
for Stewart running isn't a choice
it's a necessity this is a chair from
Emily
Rob from Park runs
[Applause]
to marathons
exercise is one of the many ways Stuart
is reducing his risk of dementia
that's according to a new health
checklist by Alzheimer's research UK
essentially an mot for the brain with
advice like staying active looking after
your hearing socializing protecting your
mental health and getting at least seven
hours sleep around 60 to 70 percent of
your risk is due to genetic factors
things that you've inherited but 30 to
40 percent of your risk is are things
that are potentially modifiable during
your life
for stewards the guidance is Gospel it's
very much worth doing that when you
consider the the heartache and the
devastation that Alzheimer's and
Dementia can bring
the advice from the lamby family take it
from someone who knows these small steps
can have a big impact suburi Sky News
Taiwan is where China may use Force
against the island in the coming years
in an effort to distract from president
XI jinping's domestic issues and to
cement his legacy speaking to Sky News
taiwan's foreign minister I'm said a
Chinese invasion is now more likely than
it was a year ago
to me uh 2027 is a year that we need to
watch out in 2027 Xi Jinping is likely
to go into his fourth term if you look
at the Chinese situation right now the
economy is going down people are not
happy so we are concerned that in 2027
if Xi Jinping cannot change the
situation domestically in China he might
want to resort to a use of force or
creating crisis externally to divert
domestic attention or to show to the
Chinese that he has accomplished
something and we are concerned that
Taiwan might become his scapegoat and
does that worst possible scenario now
feel more likely yes indeed if you look
at the trajectory of the Chinese
military threat against Taiwan it is
more likely
that interview conducted for us by
Helena who is in the Taiwanese capital
of Taipei this morning
um hi um helenan
um they are more anxious now than they
were a year ago
yeah absolutely the foreign minister
Joseph we was very clear about that uh
in our interview he said very clearly
that the situation has got significantly
worse and as you heard there that worst
case scenario the potential of a full
invasion from China he said now more
likely but as you were hearing In that
clip that focus on a date feels really
quite unusual because up until now
Taiwanese ministers are an officials are
pretty reluctant to commit to any sort
of timeline within which this might
happen but he said repeatedly in that
interview that he felt that 2027 date
would potentially be uh important
because of the plethoras he sees it of
domestic issues that President Xi
Jinping of China faces remember China
sees this self-governing island as its
own even though Taiwan has never been
controlled by the Communist Party of
China but we spoke about a range of
issues K and there were other very
interesting things that Joseph Wu said
for instance he said that he thinks it's
possible that at some point in the
future What's called the currency status
quo will no longer be the case now the
sweetest Crow is this careful balancing
act that Taiwan has whereby it doesn't
officially declare independence but it
doesn't concede to China it kind of sits
somewhere in the middle he said that he
thinks it's possible that that won't
always be the case that's a pretty rare
admission that perhaps one day in the
future Taiwan will either be independent
or come under Chinese control and he
spoke 2K about the very perilous
situation that exists between Chinese
and Taiwanese fighter jets almost every
day now Chinese fighter jets are flying
towards Taiwanese airspace they are
crossing what we call the median line
which is the unofficial Maritime border
and when that happens Taiwanese Jets
scramble to try and intercept them and
the minister said how worried they are
that a misstep a mistake an accident
could spiral into war and that could be
very serious indeed he did say that the
Taiwanese would be willing to negotiate
in good faith with the Chinese that said
very clearly that they would not be
willing to concede to any precept
political condition by China okay for no
thank you Helena
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you on the breakfast show
here on Sky news this morning America's
secretary of state has hinted that more
support could be on the way for Ukraine
following talks with the foreign
secretary James cleverley in Washington
speaking at a joint news conference
Anthony blinken warned that Russia's war
in Ukraine is likely to go on for some
time and now is the moment to ramp up
military aid
it starts with their own courage and
resilience but it's certainly been
strongly supported by our two countries
and many other countries and we continue
to adapt along the way now all of that
totals
for the on the part of the United States
some 25 billion dollars in security
assistance to Ukraine uh over less than
uh less than a year
um and I would anticipate that you'll
hear more announcements in the days to
come there'll be a meeting again at the
end of the week of the so-called
Ramstein group that secretary Austin put
together to make sure that we're
coordinating security assistance among
many countries so stay tuned uh for for
more on that
and the Russian foreign minister Sergey
lavrov who is holding his annual news
conference this morning at eight o'clock
UK time we're going to bring that to you
and find out what the Russian foreign
minister has to say about all sorts of
things including I'm sure the war in
Ukraine so stay tuned for more on that
in the eight o'clock hour here on the
breakfast show meantime British tech
company open bionics which is creating
3D printed bionic arms for amputees has
fitted two wounded Ukrainian Soldiers
with the technology the company is
working as part of a wider mission to
deliver Prosthetics to amputees from War
as well as Rehabilitation and canceling
at a hospital in leviv called the
superhumans Center
Billy eilish has requested a restraining
order against a man who allegedly broke
into her home earlier this month legal
documents say a 39 year old man
allegedly turned up unannounced and
uninvited at the singer's childhood home
multiple times in the last few weeks she
said this has caused substantial anxiety
fear and emotional distress
the world's oldest person a French nun
has died at the age of 118.
Lucille random was born in 1904 she took
the name of sister Andre when she joined
a Catholic charitable order in
1944. she survived two Global Health
crises Spanish Flu in 1918 and of course
covered over the last few years sadly
has now passed away may she rest in
peace
the Met Office has issued a number of
weather warnings across the UK as the
cold and frosty conditions continue to
bite
get these pictures of snow along the
coast in Cornwall that may have melted
by this morning with rain forecast for
overnight in the country but yellow
weather warnings are in place for snow
and ice across large areas of the
country let's get more should we coastly
standing by for us this morning it's
been flipping freezing the last couple
of days what's going to happen over the
next couple of days
morning case stays pretty cold for the
next few days it will gradually turn
milder this weekend but it takes some
time the mild air gradually coming from
the Northwest so parts of the southeast
for example stay pretty cool throughout
the weekend and see an increasing risk
of fog and freezing fog but that's a few
days away at the moment we're talking
about quite cold Frosty icy conditions
and as you mentioned there are a myriad
of weather warnings out across the UK
and Ireland for snow and ice now it's
mainly affecting northern and western
areas we're exposed to the wind but also
across parts of Eastern areas as well
we've also got some of them the wintry
showers from yesterday are still
affecting some parts of Eastern parts of
the UK as well along those North Sea
facing coasts so plenty of places at
risk of snow and night you'll notice the
ice warning in the far south of England
that's because here we've also seen
quite a lot of runoff from surface
runoff from the recent rains we've had
in some of the fields so we are
expecting to see still some icy
conditions which does make traveling
conditions quite tricky so if you are
are up and about early this morning do
take extra caution on the roads and the
Pavements just to watch out for any icy
surfaces
take a look at the details hello again
everybody welcome back to the breakfast
show here on Sky News the Home Secretary
has said Revelations of the crimes of
yet another metropolitan police officer
Were A Dark Day for police saying David
Carrick was officially dismissed from
the force yesterday after admitting 49
criminal charges including
24 counts of rape earlier the
immigration Minister Robert generick
backed calls to scrap carrot carrick's
access to his metropolitan police
pension
foreign
the forfeiture of the pension is a
matter for the mayor of London but we
support his efforts to remove that
pension if that is indeed what he
chooses to do you know this is one of
the most egregious cases of police
misconduct in the history of the Met
perhaps in the history of British
policing and this disgusting individual
should not benefit from his years
serving in the metropolitan police
uh tomorrow so you're not mincing his
words there was he no absolutely not but
of course the decision to strip David
Carrick of his pension is actually not
taken by ministers it will be taken uh
whether he was in the Met by the Mets by
the London mayor's office for policing
and crime so Sadiq Khan the London mayor
essentially and normally you could only
do that if a police officer has
committed a serious crime while on duty
and the difficulty is that many of these
crimes although linked to him being a
police officer were not committed while
he was on duty and so that's what will
have to be considered and it may be that
he ends up keeping in previous cases
when this is happening there aren't very
many of them but the police officers end
up keeping about 35 of it so they may
not be able to strip him of the whole
thing and one newspaper's worked out
this morning if he was earning around 43
000 pounds at that rank in the police
that would give him a pension of 22 000
a year in his retirement so if he kept a
third of that that's still quite a big
outlay for the taxpayer and of course
many of the victims will feel very
insulted by the okay tomorrow for now
thank you let's get more now should we
on that story one of carrick's victims
told us he was manipulating evil and had
boasted of protecting Barack Obama and
the queen our crime correspondent Martin
brunt has more for us
this is PC David Carrick showing off the
house where he raped some of his victims
into uh my bedroom his new partner had
just moved in
she became his next victim
clutter everywhere as usual
over the side
the view from our window the woman who's
now in her 40s talked about the man she
fell for
he boasted about his job at the Met he
told me the safest place I can be was
with him at first he was the dream man
he was so Charming but over time that
changed
she said Carrick raped and assaulted her
repeatedly and once when a young girl
annoyed him she said the Firearms
officer shot her with a pellet gun
he was so evil I have no idea how
someone so messed up can be a police
officer never mind give him a gun if
he'd shot someone I wouldn't have been
surprised
this was the cupboard where Carrick
locked up some of his victims but not
her she said
Carrick boasted of guarding the queen
and Barack Obama she said and she met
his police colleagues
when I started to speak to his friends
he would stop me he didn't want me
talking to anyone a couple of his
colleagues reached out to me after that
a couple have been in touch since his
arrest as well
this week Carrick admitted 49 attacks on
women over many years as a police
officer finally he's just been sacked by
the Met after a disciplinary hearing
even the Home Secretary couldn't believe
how long it had taken
yesterday was a dark day for British
policing and the Metropolitan Police as
an officer admitted being responsible
for a monstrous campaign of abuse
bureaucracy and process
appear to have prevailed over ethics and
Common Sense
finally
the victim said she cried when Carrick
was finally arrested
she said he doesn't deserve to get out
of prison ever
Martin brunt Sky News
and if you scan the QR code on your
screen right now then you can listen to
this morning's Sky News Daily podcast as
a former met police officer David
Carrick faced his life in prison for
multiple counts of rape Neil Patterson
speaks to a former officer and a
campaigner about the forces struggle to
root out sexual abusers in their own
ranks
governments insisted it respects
Devolution in Scotland as it defended
blocking Hollywood's gender Reform Bill
the controversial legislation which
removes some restrictions on people
wishing to change their gender not set
to go before the courts with the SMP
branding the Westminster intervention an
unprecedented attack on the Scottish
Parliament joined by spokesperson for
Scotland Dr Philippa Whitford SNP of
course it's nice to see thanks for
joining us on the program this morning
do you accept
any legal concerns At All by the prime
minister
no I don't I mean this legislation was
before the Scottish Parliament for six
years it's the most consulted piece of
legislation they had lots of expert
input they had their own equalities
committee look at it there are a lot of
women's groups in Scotland who have been
supportive of it it doesn't change any
of the rights you have with a gender
recognition certificate it doesn't give
any extra anything it doesn't change the
equality act exemptions at all it just
simplifies and shortens the process of
getting one and in particular removes
this medicalization the need to have a
psychological diagnosis of gender
dysphoria and that is actually just in
keeping with who recommendations un
recommendations and actually where many
other countries have already got to and
where many other countries like Germany
and Spain are moving the um the age 16
seems to be the sticking point for many
well yeah that was raised but you know
in Scotland people have been able to
marry at 16 for hundreds of years if you
remember that's the whole basis of
Gretna Green we have 16 year old voting
so a lot of the narrative and when we
you know we waited for this list of
reasons
um yes age was one of the things in
there but actually a lot of it was just
we can't be having two systems we can't
be having two laws it would be
complicated to have two different gender
recognition systems well that's the
basis of devolution is that you do have
different laws
oh but they can be overridden by the
British government which is what yes and
and obviously this is unprecedented to
veto it like this and I think that you
know the group that we need to think
about in this is transgender people who
have watched this build takes so long to
go through the Scottish Parliament I
noticed your Trail earlier was you know
Nicholas sturgeon versus Rishi sunak
it's not this is parliaments this was
passed by over two-thirds of the msps in
the Scottish Parliament and that's from
all parties so you know this is really
showing an attack on the Scottish
Parliament Scottish labor party we're
concerned about the number 16 as well of
course people have concerns and the idea
that you know everyone thinks that all
of this is good or people don't have
concerns about it you know that's for
the birds of course people will argue
about it that's what politicians do but
they work their way through 150
amendments as I say they had two major
consultations lots of expert input and
they accepted a lot of the Amendments
trying to make it as good a piece of
legislation as possible including
putting on the face of the bill that it
the equalities Act of 2010 has Primacy
and that it does not change any of the
exemptions within that okay if trans
rights are so important to the SNP would
it not be worth accepting the offer from
Aleister Jack who is the Scotland
secretary to offer to redraft the bill
well the thing is they had six years
they didn't respond to any of the
consultations
um
Shona Roberson wrote to them in October
she finally got a reply at the end of
December she got to meet Kami badinok
the day before the final stage so if
they had all these incredible concerns
as it went through it's not been secret
it's had lots of coverage and debate and
public debate and media debate why did
they not come forward then and say we're
really anxious about this bit and if you
listen to what he said yesterday they
basically the only modification they
would accept is going back to the
medicalized route which is not what is
recommended by the UN Human Rights let's
about it on a human level does this not
open up vulnerable young people to
assign their own gender when they might
not be 100 sure well obviously within
that it's a longer waiting time and it
also has kind of other Protections in
you know who they've consulted who is
supporting them in their family Etc to
to look at this it's still not going to
be a terribly quick process for a young
person and and there is very much that
they need to look at that but if you
talk to people who are transgender it's
not something that they just choose to
do at a certain age it's something they
have felt usually their whole lives and
the younger people they consulted with
didn't want to have the opportunity to
access that taken away from them and
that's why the age has dropped and you
know as it has for many other things
talk to me about what would happen if
for example someone was born as a man
identified as a man I was born as a man
but then wanted to identify as a woman
in Scotland came to England
fell foul of the law which prison would
they go to
well obviously the the
um the prisoners stay already judges
people on a case-by-case basis whether
you've gone through gender recognition
whether you've had surgery Etc or not
it's on a case-by-case basis including
you know there are many people who are
kept separate from the rest of the
population they've changed their gender
in Scotland they come to England a
country that does not acknowledge that
law which prison would they be put in
well obviously that would be up to the
English prison system and it might well
be that they would if they're not
recognizing that that they would put
them in uh they would put them in a male
prison but equally they'd be incredibly
vulnerable there yeah yeah and then the
psychological impact of someone who
found themselves in that position
because of a law in Scotland
so you think actually they shouldn't
have been allowed to change their gender
in the first place I don't I don't know
I'm asking you to explain to me the
circumstances that somebody might quite
literally find themselves in but that's
up to the English prison system and your
solution to that is they shouldn't be
allowed to change their gender at all
you know at the moment if they change
their gender the prison system has to
assess are they a danger to someone else
are other people a danger to them and
the prison systems already do that in
the same way as they do with people who
might be at risk in the prison
population for other reasons
you're going to ask the courts to decide
if they find oh we've no other choice I
mean it's not it's not where we want to
be what then
well obviously that's up to the Scottish
government rather than me
um but we will be fighting that hard in
the courts and you know if you look at
it gender reassignment gender
recognition is devolved so it's not
Beyond competence that's already been
ruled on in Scotland and it clearly and
purposefully does not change anything in
the equality act so if you look at his
page of reasons and it's on the internet
most of it is a load of waffle and
hypotheticals and basically boils down
to half of it is we can't have something
different north of the border and the
other half is oh if it's easier more
people might have a certificate and
therefore it's more bother
you know this is treating all trans
people like they are a threat and and
they're the ones that are getting lost
in all of this
um what's the relationship like between
Hollywood and Westminster at the moment
well I don't think it's great obviously
after after yesterday uh clearly Rishi
sunak at least was open to speaking to
our first Minister unlike the former
prime minister who wanted to ignore her
but I don't think this helps
relationships at all this is clearly a
devolved matter as you'll be aware we're
you know starting to to work also today
on the retained EU law Bill and a lot of
the things that will be struck down are
things that are also within devolved
competence the Scottish Parliament
hasn't given consent to that because
frankly it's a dangerous piece of
legislation that could allow standards
safety standards to just fall away
without being reviewed and some of those
are actually devolved areas and they're
not working in Partnership if they
should be bringing the ones they
specifically want to change and debating
that sounds like we'll be talking quite
a lot over the next few months it's good
thank you very much indeed thank you
very much I appreciate it thank you time
for a look at some of the images that
have caught I in the papers this morning
particularly like this one five-year-old
boy's Dream came true this week after
Durham Police will tell you about that
actually I'm looking at this one to
start with let's do this one to start
with should we this how much do you
think this Podium cost
four thousand pounds four thousand
pounds is what Liz trust decided a
Podium was worth in order to make her
first speech as prime minister
um interesting isn't it uh
4175 pounds to be precise uh now let me
tell you about that little boy
here we go here he is he wanted to be a
police officer when he grows up his mum
he's recently lost his daddy his mum
wrote to Durham Police four outriders
came along to his neighborhood and they
even got him his own little motorbike
with stabilizers on absolutely love it
uh Harry Farrell is his name mum Emma
organizing that surprise for him
now if you were up early enough in
Scotland this morning you may have seen
a pretty impressive display up in the
sky take a look at this there it all
there you go Aurora Borealis some people
go to Iceland or Lapland to try and see
that if you're up in Scotland you could
see it for yourself Aurora Borealis more
commonly known as the northern lights
and they were filmed by a couple
traveling home from Once which is part
of Scotland's Shetland Islands the green
waves caused by something called coronal
mass ejection a large expulsion of
plasma and magnetic field from the sun's
surface and it catches the pollution in
the sky and that's what happens clever
huh no the government's plan to set
minimum service levels during strikes in
key public sectors is now making its way
through Parliament they say the
legislation would keep the public safe
labor and the unions argue it would stop
some workers ever striking with some
even arguing it breaches international
law it's a complex issue but here to
give us some insight is employment law
specialist Melanie Stan clip hi it's
good to see you thank you so much for
taking the time to join us and there's a
lot of talk about what the government is
trying to do with a minimum number of
workers having to work if a strike is
called
um the business secretary
says the government defends the
principle that workers can withdraw
their labor is that you're into is is
that is that your interpretation of of
the situation not really I think the way
the the law will work if it becomes law
will be that individuals who wanted to
strike who voted to strike could be told
no you have got to work and that will
come from their Union because their
employer will tell their union we need
these people to do this job to ensure
the minimum service okay
um often when government ministers are
sat there they say to me this is the
situation in other European countries
including Spain and France is that the
case no it's not in fact the legislation
has never been used in France that does
the same thing so even though we
perceive that France might have lots of
strikes they don't use this in the same
way okay should the government in your
view
continue with the legislation given your
expertise
I think the the legislation will
guarantee or will bring in a minimum
service level but it's just a minimum
and that is the problem which it doesn't
resolve the underlying dispute and it
doesn't ensure that individuals get the
appointments that they need in the NHS
it doesn't ensure that everybody can get
to work it perhaps means one train an
hour from certain places so I think the
better thing would be to look at
resolving the underlying issues
what are the rights currently
the current position is that an employee
who votes and has a ballot that's a
properly organized ballot if they vote
to go out on strike they can go out and
strike and they're protected if they're
dismissed for that but that will change
they will lose that dismiss that
protection from dismissal if they go out
on strike and flout an order from the
employer to provide work so does that
mean
um if say an ambulance worker
refuses to go to work when he's he or
she is told to they can be sacked
um any employer could sack somebody at
any point the question is do they have
protection from unfair dismissal and and
we're under this new law they could lose
that protection if they've been given
this work notice and then they flout
that there's also implications for the
union because the union has to take
reasonable steps to make sure their
staff are their union members are
attending if they're named in that
notice okay and how about agency workers
how can they be used on strike days
um I think it would be the backup plan
there's obviously issues about people
having the skills the experience the
expertise to deliver the service that's
needed in some Industries we already
have long long vacancy lists we have you
know shortages and it's very difficult
to get the staff to perform the roles we
need
do you think
um given your expertise it's fair and
reasonable for the government to bring
in this law
I think this Law whatever it ends up
looking like will be tested we know that
the House of Lords are going to look at
it very closely we know that there are
unions who are already mounting legal
challenges there are issues about
whether it flouts the the right to
assemble under the Human Rights Act and
so I think that there will be litigation
that follows and I I don't think the
issue would be whether it's fair that
the equation will be whether it's legal
okay good to see you thank you so much
for coming in and explain that to us
very complicated isn't it thank you now
the Prince of Wales has revealed his
love of stakes when he joined a cooking
class for young carers here we go Prince
William or an apron
um and met some of those to try to talk
more about the charity together as one
which was founded almost 25 years ago to
tackle gang violence in Slough it comes
during a difficult period for the royal
family with Prince Harry making a series
of damaging allegations in TV views and
his recently published Memoir spare
apparently the whole point of the
charity is for conflict resolution
now today is Kevin Costner's 68th
birthday the American actor is probably
best known for his appearance in Dances
with Wolves for which he won not one but
two Oscars he also starred in The
Untouchables and Field of Dreams which I
thought was a particularly fabulous
movie happy birthday Kevin Costner who
is 68 today
of today's top stories coming up stay
tuned